よろしくお願いします
今日の話はこの法華経の十三番目と十四番目になります Yatha
agāraṃ ducchannaṃ vuṭṭhi samativijjati. Evaṃ abhāvitaṃ
cittaṃ rāgo samativijjati.
Yathā agārasm ducchannaṃ vuṭṭhi na samativijjat
i. Evaṃ subhāvitaṃ cittaṃ rāgo
na samativijjati. という二つの偈です
それほどというか あまり難しくないんですよ
ものすごい単純で簡単で理解できる偈二つだと思います
意味は agāram ducchannaṃ という言葉がありますね
agāram というのは家
ducchannaṃ というのはいい加減で
屋根を 何と言いますか
葺く？屋根をいい加減で葺いていると
その家のように 家の屋根がいい加減に作ると
昔は屋根っていうのは瓦ではなくてね
瓦で屋根を作る場合は宮殿みたいなものだけでしたから
当然インドでは瓦やら何でしたっけ
レンガやらね それは昔から
遠い昔からあったもんですけど
大体家っていうのはそこら辺の河童で屋根を葺いておくんですね
日本で言えば何でしたっけ
茅葺き 屋根というものは立派なものありますけど
でもそれはそう簡単ではないんですよ
葺くのはね かなり厳密に屋根を作らないといけないんですね
その場合は vuṭṭhi samativijjati
vuṭṭhiっていうのは雨
samatiっていうのはできますということ
動詞ですね  vijjatiっていうのは
何か貫いていく場合はvijjatiという言葉を使いますね
何か通して貫いていくという意味はvijjatiですね
そちらはいろいろ意味があり
例えば矢を撃っちゃうと
その場合もvijjatiという言葉を使いますね
矢を撃ってもぶつけて穴を開けて中へ入りますからね
その時も同じ動詞を使います
そこで雨が屋根を通して貫いて中に入るということなんですね
それは samati できますと
雨に貫くことできますという意味なんですね
それは直訳でそうなりますけどね
ただ雨漏りをしますと evaṃ
abhāvitaṃ cittaṃ
evaṃ このように abhāvitaṃ bhāvita
abhāvitaという二つの言葉
abhāvitaṃというのは向上させなかったというね
成長させなかったという
育てなかったというね
いくつかの意味がありますね
次の言葉はcittaṃ
心ですね 向上させなかった
よく育てなかった心 rāgo
rāgoっていうのは欲ということで samativijjati
貫くことはできますと
心の中に入ってしまいますね
ラーガが そこで訳ではね
欲はね 情欲と書いてますからね
それで十四番目になると
そちらのただ反対の言葉だけなんですね
ね という言葉を入れてるだけで
ヤターアガーランスッチャンナン
アガーランイエスッチャンナン
とても上手に吹いている場合は
とても丁寧に吹いている場合は
ブッダ雨がなサマティヴィッジャティ
漏れることはできない
エワンすすバビタンチッタン
アバビタの反対 スバビタンというね
スバビタン よく上手に育てた心
スバハビタっていうのはとても丁寧に丹念に心を育てたっていうことなんですね
その心の場合はラーゴナサマティヴィッジャティ
情欲は貫くこと 入り込むことはできませんと
まあそれぞれまあ文字通りの意味で
そんなに難しい 大変わかりにくいということはないんです
そういうふうに この簡単にわかりやすく
覚えやすく まあ唱え まあ教えられているというものは
やっぱり我々はよく頭の中で覚えておいた方が
私たちをすごく悪いところから守ってくれるんですよ
で この偈もね ものすごい簡単に覚えやすい偈で
あの あるいはあまりも単純だから
日本語ももう五七五でしたっけ
そういうふうな形に入れ替えることもできます
どんな偈でもできるわけじゃないんですよ
ものすごい微妙に意味が変わるすごい難しいものもありますけど
こういうふうなものだったら
まあ五七五の節に書き換えることもできます
だからそういうできるものはもう日本語らしい日本語に入れ替えても
んじゃないかなと その場合は覚えやすいしね
何か自分のものになってしまうしね
できればそういうふうに頑張ってチャレンジしてみてください
まあ一つ二つうまくいったんだからって
どんな経典の偈でもね
ちゃんとした日本の節に書いて書き換えてみるそうと思っても
これはもう天才みたいな能力がないとはできないとは思います
よく育てる心をよく育てるっていうことが難しい
よくわかんないんですけど
だからそこら辺はそれ適当に考えればいいんです
例えば詩にするならばね
で まあ一応これから仏教的な解釈ではなくてね
説明はいたしますけど
仏教は何を説いてますか？やっぱり心を育てることですね
一貫してずっと言ってるのは
でお釈迦様の仏教の場合はね
徹底的に心の問題という他ほとんどないんですよ
もうたまたまこの俗世間のことも語ってはいますけど
仏教のメインテーマではないんです
財産はどうしますかとか
仕事はどうしますかとかね
で 家の財産を守るためにどうしますかとか
そんなのはもうたまたまお釈迦様に聞かれたら教えますけど
そんなことを言うために現れたわけじゃないんです
商売繁盛の秘訣を解き明かすために現れたわけじゃないんです
ですから この仏教はもうずっともう一貫して心を育てるというテーマなんですね
その理由が 仏教は物事は如実に見る
ありのままに見る 証拠に基づいて見る
因果法則にのっとって物事を見る
だから かすかにでもこの違う
なんか自分の主観 自分の好み
みんな言ってること そうでなかろうかという推測などは入れません
入れちゃうとこの具体性から脱出するんだと
だから 100%正しいということにならないというところで
そこら辺難しい話になりますけど
で そこで私たちは生きている人間が自分の人生を観察してみる
自分の人生観察して見てみると
期待通りに生きる場合もあるし
期待通りにいかないこともあるし
もう幸福になる 楽しくなる時もあるし
悲しくなる時もあるし
で いろんな出来事を人生の中で起きて起きるんですね
それは自分の人生観察したっても
もうめちゃくちゃいろんなことを生きているということはわかるでしょうし
で 一般的な社会のどんな人の人生を見てみても
社会全体的な生き方を見てみても
大体同じパターンで見えてくるはずなんですよ
いわゆるまとめて言えばうまくいかないと
大体はもう 99%ぐらいはもう人生について世界について聞けば結論で言えるのはうまくいかないんだと
その一言で言えるんですよ
このうまくいかないんだという言葉ですよ
大体ドッカだというふうな言葉に入れているのは
だから その言葉の中にその意味も当たり前当然なことも入っているんです
うまくいかないんだと
それで絶対うまくいかないというと成り立たないんですね
とにかく何とか生きているんだから
絶対うまくいかないわけではなくて
うまくいかないというぐらいのことなんです
で まあなんとかまあなんとか間に合って生きているというかね
ということが一応正しい結論になるんですよ
なんとか生きているんだと
万々歳状態でうまくいくかというと
それはほとんどない 誰にもない
それでまあ十万人に百万人に一人がうまくいってるんだからといって
それは科学的なデータにはなりませんね
どんなものにでもあれやりますから EXCEPTION
というのは何でしたっけ？例外というのはね
たまたま例外一つあったんだからって
それだけ出してね もう喋ってはいけないんですよ
で これにいい例っていうのは宝くじなんですよ
宝くじ当たったらもうどうせもう万々歳で楽しくて
それからもう人生困らなくてもいいと
といえばその通りなんですけど
正しいのは当たらないっていうことなんですよ
しかし 人間っていうのは
でも誰かに当たるでしょうと
でも  1等賞は一つか二つ
三つしかないんですけど
だから決して私は宝くじが当たって幸福な人生をしますということは話にならないんですよ
私はこれから豊かな人間になりますと
方法は宝くじの 1等賞当たってもらうと
これは話にならないんですよ
何の経済的な思考にも
何にも使うことはできない
例外みたいなもんですからね
ですから 人間の中でも
もう 100万人に何100万人に一人ぐらいは
まあそれほど問題はなく
見た目ではうまくいっているかもしれませんですけどね
しかし そういうものは例外であって出してはいけない
人間がそればっかりやってるんですよ
大体我々は考える時は
このもう珍しくうまくいっている人のことばっかり考えて
それが哲学的にもう喋ろうとする
あんまり意味がないんです
ですから 仏教の立場はあまりものすごい具体的に見る
具体的に見ると やっぱりうまくいかないということは正しいことなんですよ
正しい観察なんですね
人生はうまくいかないと
それで我々は あの人はやっぱりあまりにも恵まれているんだよという人がいても
お釈迦様にその人の人生を見てみても
うまくいっているはずがないんだと
例えば どんな人でも年は取りたくないと思っているでしょうし
その人はどうですかと
避けられないんだからね
他のこと何がうまくいったっても
時間とは戦えませんだからね
時間と一緒に老化していく
[背景音楽]病気になれないと思っても
なる可能性はある 死ぬまで全く病気にならない人々もいますが
それもお釈迦様ちゃんとおっしゃってますよ
この中でもう年でも全然くしゃみぐらいでも病気がない人もいますよと
それは何のために言ったんですかというと
でも一秒でも心の病で悩んでいない
悩まない人はいませんよと
体がもう年経っても何一つも風邪引いたことない人っていうのは調べればいる
しかし 心はちょっと瞬間だけでも悩まないということはないんだと
その場合は悩むと言ったっても病病気ですね
使ってた言葉は そういう論理で見ると
私たちから見てうまくいってる人にしても
精神的な悩みがあるはずなんですね
それから年は取る 死ななくちゃいけない
幸福三昧の人に限って死ぬことは一番苦しいんですよ
不幸のどん底の人は もう
すごい自分で出て自殺するんだからね
死んだ方がマシだと 不幸のどん底の人が自殺する気持ちになるならば
同じ論理で考えると 幸福の絶頂にいる人が逆でしょ
絶対死にたくないという立場になっちゃうんですね
ですから その人にとってはものすごい苦しいんですよ
死ぬことは そういうわけで
人間の人生はうまくいかないと
それで人生だけ 人間だけ見てもそういうことで
もうどんな生命を見てもそううまくいかないっていうことは
お釈迦様には見えていて
かなりスケール大きく考えているんですね
うまくはいかないと いかなる生命でも
やっぱり生死を乗り越えられない
生と死の間であらゆる変化が起こる
どんな変化が起きても
結局死へ向かって起こる変化だから
楽しいわけじゃないんです
そこまでは誰にでも客観的に変な思考を導入しないで
変な概念 変な感情 好き嫌い導入しないで
全く冷静に科学者と同じ態度で観察すると
それぐらいのことはわかるはずなんですよ
次のステップはなんででしょうかっていうことなんですね
なんでうまくいかないかと
そこで宗教と哲学者 いろんな人々の差が出てくるんですね
これなんででしょうかと原因を探す場合は
みんなもう脱線するんですね
具体的な観察から そこで好き嫌いやら伝統やら
いろんなもの 文化やら
いろんなものが割り込んじゃう
そこで思考が汚れてしまう
正しい答えが出てこないんですね
例えば 人間が神に創造されたという考え方は
初めからの観察能力が乏しいんですよ
人生はうまくいかないんだよという能力が
具体的な観察能力があったならば
それに基づいて これが絶対的な神が作ったよという考え方は出てこないはずなんです
だから この神が作ったんだぞという人々が
この初めからの観察能力はちょっとおかしい
で 唯一何か一つの例外だけ
億人の一人に起こることを見て考えたことなんですね
だからこの人間っていうのはとても素晴らしくて
とても幸せで あまりにも楽しく生きてるんだよという前提で神をセッティングしているんですよ
それコーランでね  一番最初の行で出てくる
最初の章は行 語句でできてますけどね
オンリーガードということで
モーストコンパッショネート
だからすべて与えてくれる
ものすごい何ですか 慈しみの神であるというね
それが絶対的な神っていうことで
だから絶対的な神が絶対的な慈しみを持っていると
なぜそんなことを言ってるかというと
私たちはだから幸せで楽しく生きてるんだよという考え方なんです
だから そういう人々は
人間がなんて素晴らしく楽しく幸福で生きてるんでしょうかというところで神を創造するんですよ
それで仏教の見方は まあちょっとすごく変わってるんですね
本当に生きることは そんなにも万々歳で
希望通りに期待通りにいくんでしょうかと
よくよく見るとうまくいかないっていうことではないかと
だから神がいる いないということさえも
仏教は時間使わない 無駄な時間だと
神について語ることさえも
それぐらいもうもう考えてもしない
考えることさえもしないぐらいで話にしているのです
それでまあ なぜ人生はうまくいかないかと
なぜ我々の生き方はあまりうまくいかないかと
言うと その場合でも お釈迦様がすごく客観的に
ものすごく合理的に 原因結果という因果法則に基づいて観察する
それはまたいわゆるありのままに見るということになるんです
ありのままに見る 変な概念を入れないで見る
自分の主観を入れないで見る
自分の感情を導入しないで見る
ありのままで見たら それで心ということは明確に見えてくる
例えば 商売しようと出かけた人はそこら辺で喧嘩になって怪我して
品物も全部なくなって家に戻ったとする
売りたくと持っていた品物も全部奪われちゃって
その上その人と殴られてすごい大喧嘩になってとか
だからうまくいかなかったでしょ
その場合 なんでその人はうまくいかなかったと
それは誰にでもチェックできます
その置いていたところで喧嘩になったと
だから喧嘩したのはそこで怒りでしょうに
怒った 誰が怒ってもいいんですからね
この人は怒らなくても相手が怒ったならばね
で まあ相手が怒ったらそれでも喧嘩になるし
[音楽]それで相手の人にしても
この人にしても 儲かりたいというね
気持ちがあるでしょうに
それで自分がもう自分の財産を守るために
もう売った喧嘩を買ってしまったと
そういうことになるでしょうし
ですから 商売に行った人が財産も品物も全部奪われちゃって
怪我までしてもう家に戻ったならば
そこら辺ではっきりわかるのは
その人間の考え方 怒り
欲などなどでしょうね
どちらでも私が幸せになりたいと
人のことは関係ないというね
わがままとかね そういうふうにもうはっきり見えてくるんですよ
そこでお釈迦様の時代で
かなり政治的に 激しい変化があった時代だからね
政治的に激しいっていうのはいつでもあることで
今もあることでね そこである国がものすごく平和で
法律にのっとって国を治めていても
隣の国にやられてしまう
そこは何でしょうかと
この国の政府がものすごく平和で
国民みんなのことを平等に見て
何の問題もなく政治しているのに
なぜ隣の国に戦略 今はそういう場合はそれほどないんですけど
昔はもう平和な国であるならばやられちゃうという
奪われちゃうと その時でも見えてくるのは
隣の国の人 王が狂暴で権力欲で
自分の土地をとことんどこまででも広げたいというすごい欲があって
残酷な気持ちで相手のことはどうでもいいと
何人死んだっても自分が勝つぞと
で そういう思考があるんだから
まあいい人も潰れてしまうんですよ
そういう風にちゃんと見てみるならば
世の中をね それで心ということは明確に出てくるはずなんです
神は出てこないはずなんです
だから平和でいる国は潰れたのは
その国は平和だけだけで神を信仰していなかったと
だから神の怒りが落ちたと
なんとかくだらんことを言う必要はないんです
それでお釈迦様には原因として心は見えるんであって
それをまたそんなに不可思議な神秘的なことではないんですね
すごい単純でわかりやすいものなんですね
個人個人で見ても同じこと見えてくる
社会を見ても同じこと見えてくる
自分がなんで失敗したんですか？と言えば
やっぱり自分の心の問題であると
物事を判断できなかったとかね
あるいは欲 あまりにも欲が入り込んじゃって
ちょっと誤算してしまったとかね
例えば商売繁盛するぞと
これこれを売って こういう風にして
それでずっと計算はするんだけど
客観的な計算にならなくなっちゃうんだよ
儲かりたい 儲かりたいという気持ちが入っていると
そこで何か計画を立てて実行したところで
もう儲かるところがすごく大損してしまったということはいつでもあり得る
それが神のせいでも誰のせいでもなく
自分には明確な論理的な知識能力がなかったということなんですね
判断ミスを犯したということなんですよ
そういうふうにどこまで調べてみても
それでお釈迦様それはとことんとことん厳密に超越した知恵で厳密に調べたところでも
心と物質のこのからくりであるということは
他は何もないと そういうことだから
当然ながら人間が育てるべきなのは心であるということになってくる
神様の機嫌を取るのではなくて
心を育てると 例えば 人は神様にお祈りして幸福になったとしたっても
同じ法則やと お祈りしてお祈りして
もう本当に祈りを聞いてくれて幸せになったと言えば
それも明確に心の法則ではないかと
例えば その人が 100%の証拠を持ってきて
自分は確かに神様が幸福にしてくれたと
他誰でもないんだと 例えば
神様のお祈りして土を掘ったところで金脈を見つかりましたと
その場合はやはり祈りを聞いたと言っても証拠は足らないんですね
例えば 私はお祈りしたところで
自分の家でドーンと 金が現れたんだと
金というのは普通土を掘っていろんな過程を経て得なくちゃいけないもので
しかし 私が祈りしかしなかった
それでいきなり純金がものすごい大量に家に現れたと
これは神が作ったということしか言えないんだと言えば証拠は十分でしょう
一応完璧ではないんですけど
まあ かなり証拠は十分ですね
そういうことあったとしても
仏教から見れば あんた神様の機嫌取ったでしょうと祈りにお祈りして
だから心なんですよ でもそこまでは証拠は人間には出せないし
偉大なる神は威張ってはいるんだけど
一回だけでも一度だけでも
そういうすごいことをやったことはないんだからね
そうやったとしても 仏教の論理は崩れません
だから一貫して心を育てましょうと
それで世の中をさらに調べてみると
人が何で成功しますかと
その人は感情に負けないで
ものすごく理性に基づいて頑張っている
忍耐強い 家庭をものすごくうまく幸福で
養っているならば その家庭の大人たちがすごく忍耐強く
広い心で努力しているんですよ
ですから うまくいっている場合でも
心がそれなりに管理しているということは見えてくる
ですから お釈迦様はわかりやすく己の心を
なさいよと 神秘はありませんと
何のも それはもっともっと言葉を変えて私は言うのは
この世の中で一切すべての問題は思考から生まれる問題よと
思考と言ったっても 結局妄想いい加減な考え方ですからね
思考だったらそんなに難しくないんですよ
データがあると考えるんであって
なかったら考えないんだからね
ですから どんな問題でも
思考のことで 昨日あのの話終わったところで
ちょっと個人的な話があって
自分の国のことで この国のこの内戦状態をね
内戦じゃないんですけど
明らかにテロたちがね
もうものすごい人を殺して殺して殺して
もう空港まで爆破してさせてね
もう全部スリランカ国の飛行機を全部もう破壊したりとかね
あまりにも損害与えたりして
それで日本で一応あの平和的に仲良くしようということで
日本の政府も応援してるんではないかとかね
話が出てきてね そこでまあ私もずっと前からもね
いろんな国々にはテロを応援していたんだから
まあ勝手にやればいいんじゃない
興味はないんだと 全くも
で それで仲良くして いえ
仲良くするんじゃなくて
これからはこのテロたちが一応国を分離しないんではない
分離する必要ないんだと
今の政府はもう全部テロたちに権力を与えることにしてるんだと
10%15%の人々に人口から見ると
それで仏教の人々 まあ放っておけばいいでしょ
仏教の人々から私たちを殺さなきゃ
それで十分じゃないかと
ずっと仏教の人々殺されてきたのに
各国の新聞で仏教徒がかわいそうにこの少数民族を殺してるんだと一人も殺したことがないんですよ
仏教徒がいて そちらに殺されただけなんですけど
攻撃したこともない 軍隊はもう国で法律を犯したり
暴動を起こしたり テロを爆弾をつけたりするとね
それは軍隊と警察は動かなくちゃいけないんです
全てやることは違法だから
人を殺すのは法律的じゃないんだから
だから軍隊が行ってテロを調べたり
逮捕したりすることが
これはもう坊主たちが仏教徒たちをよく日本の新聞でブラッドティースティマンスと英字新聞で書くんですよ
ブラッドティースティっていうのは何でしたっけ？何でしたっけ？知らない
単純な英語でしょうね
ブラックブラックっていうのは知ってるでしょ？ブラッドティースティっていうの知ってるでしょう
ブラックリスト  ブラッド
ティースティ知らないの？それで
血に飢えた 血に飢えた
うんうん そうそうそう
血に飢えている坊主たちとタイトルで書くんですよ
だからそこまで偉そうにマスコミでジャーナリストでね
一人だけでもお坊さんがいて
人を殺したことがあったならば
だからそこまでもうねじ曲げてねじ曲げて行ってね
仏教徒は全然立ち上がったことはないんですよ
そこで あの 80%の人口がね
もう抑えられてるんだから
その時も私はその言ったのは
まあそれでいいんじゃないんですかと
そちらが国を支配しても
国を分離することには
まあ国民は反対 テロたちもはっきり言うと分離しちゃうとダメになるんだってことはわかってるんです
だからテロをやってるだけで
何の平和解決にもこない
なぜならば テロそのものがすごいいい商売なんです
金儲けたんだから スリランカ政府よりも金持ってるんです
あらゆる国々からもうお金が入ってくる
だからテロをやめちゃうと全部商売上がっちゃうんですよ
今は平和的な契約する前に
今政府が頑張っているのは
スリランカに入ってくるすべての援助をそちらに回そうと
だから我々にも頼んだんです
あんた方は日本のお寺やいろいろなところで関係あるんではないかと
だからこの平和活動にちゃんと協力してほしいと
というのは何なのかというと
例えば日本にいるスリランカのお坊さんやら日本のお坊さんたちと一緒に学校を作ったり
いろいろ個人スケールでやっているんですよ
至る所で日本のお寺からどこからかお金が入って幼稚園を作ったとか
至る所にあるんですね
それは全部そちらに回ってほしいと
それはそれでいいんですけど
私は言ったのはこういうポイント
私言いたいのは で スリランカがかってイギリスに支配されてあったんですね
植民地になって そちら勝手に国を支配して
搾取したい放題搾取して
もう勝手にやればいいんじゃ
こっちは落ち着いていればということでね
そこで何かになったかって
別に何にもなってないんです
もっと前も一部だけオランダ人にも支配されて
もっと前 ポルトガル人に
それも一部だけですけど
ほんのわずかなところで
その時でもスリランカはそんなに全部取らなかったんですけど
今テロリストたちがいたところはずっとやられていたんですよ
ポルトガル人にも オランダ人にも
それからイギリス人にも
別にどうってことないんだと
やればいいんじゃないですかと
だから思考の問題 もしシンハラ民族が
仏教の人たちが これは仏教の国であると
だから一つの民族を優先してはいけないんだと
仏教ではずっと言っているのは
いろんな宗教があるんじゃないか
いろんな民族がいるんではないかと
だからみんなにそれぞれ自由でなければいけないと
しかし イスラム教は自分の宗教のみという態度を取っているし
その人々はカトリック教のみでなきゃいけないと
いいんじゃないかと私は思いますよ
それで根っこになるのは民主主義制度ですよ
どうせ選挙を設置するともう大衆が選べてしまいますからね
だったらやめちゃえば
選挙制度も民主主義も
どうせその人々はすごい独裁主義で
もう恐ろしい人ですけどね
テロリストのリーダーが
別にそれで困る必要はないので
だから思考なんで それぐらいの状態であろうとも
はい どうぞどうぞ勝手にやってくださいと
どうってことない スリランカの一番大きな我々の中心になるブッダジという大お寺の真ん前
お寺の土地で教会を造ってますよ
[笑い]どういう昔からお寺の土地なんです
土地は全部取って教会作るは
イスラム教のものを作るは
別に全然気にしない だから仏教見えないように
これオランダ人の時代でしょうかね
前で ものすごい大きい教会を作ったんです
今 歴史的な古い建物だから保存しているんです
そんな別にそれでなんでこのお寺の土地の土地で
また真ん前で教会作るんでしょうかとかね
喧嘩するんですよ どうそうと
道まで閉鎖したら我々はどうしますかというと
教会を通してみんな同じ道使う
ですから この問題っていうのは思考から現れるんですよ
だから 15 年間も殺されっぱなしで
向こうの思考もとにかく潰すやるそうですよ
だからインターネットで見る限り
ものすごい書いてるんですね
一人残らず殺すと 仏教徒とシンハラ人は
あんた方にはもう海しかないんだよと
ものすごい挑発するんですよ
それで私は全部調べたんですね
シンハラ人あまり英語を読まないんですし
英語を読む人でもね 誰かが反論している方
一人も仏教徒反論していないんです
書きたい放題 あんまりにもまあずーっともういろんなところで調べて調べ
それでいろんなところでこの世界的な文化というね
もうページとかいろいろニュースグループとかあるんですね
世界文化という風にあったら
スリランカの部分になったら
全部テロたちが全部全部占領しているんです
後でテロをどうして国際的に認めたところで
一部一部一部あの閉鎖されたんですけど
占領している 言いたい放題なことを言う
一人の殺す殺すぞとそこまで書くんだからね
で かなり外国のいろんな国々からまあ
あらゆる応援がありまして
だからといって問題になるのは
自分の思考にしがみつくと問題になります
相手があまりにも凶暴で変な思考を持っているとしても
まあどうそうそうという感じでいれば
問題は起こらないんですよ
というか 一応問題起こらない
そこら辺は仏教ではずっとね
まあ自分の家を奪う はい
持っていってくださいと
という風ぐらい この思考にしがみついてはいけないと
だから世の中はずっと混乱だらけで不幸だらけになっているのは
こういう変な思考でしょ
科学的な思考じゃないんだから
ある民族が自分たちが偉いというのは変な思考でしょうに
何の科学根拠もないでしょうに
なのに我々波にねじんで
だから優れているんだそうとか言って
他の人々は殺してしまう
だから やっぱり世の中客観的に見ると
世の中にある問題は心の問題であって
他は何もないんです そういうことで
お釈迦様は絶対徹底的に心を育てなさいということは言ってるんですね
それでいろんな方法を教えてますよ
大量に経典があるんだから
聖書 コーランとは随分違いますから量は
経典というもの で もう大乗経典まで入れてみるとね
もう人間にもう一生かけても読めないほど量があるんですよ
大乗経典はもうちょっと脱線しましたけどね
迷信やら盲信やら色んなものを入れて入れ込んで脱線したんですけど
でも基本的な考え方は同じなんですよ
どうすれば心が綺麗になるかというね
もうあらゆる方法論を
新しい方法論を編み込んだり編み込んだりして
経典書いたりしてるんですから
まあそれをまとめたら仏教経典ということになります
だからブッダの教えでなくても
なんとか心清らかにする方法を書いているんだから
だから我々の宿題は その方法は有効かないかっていうぐらいのことで
そういうことで このずっと心を清らかにする方法っていうのはものすごいたくさん教えているんです
で こちらでいうのはこの育てた心という言葉なんですね
育てた心の反対の言葉っていうのは
育ててない脆い心っていう意味なんですよ
心が脆い あまりも弱い
あまりも脆くて弱いんだったら
外からの攻撃はもうまだ脆に受ける
それでどうすれば心清らかになるかというね
これはもういくら語っても語りきれないほどたくさん方法っていうのはあるんでしょうし
だから喧嘩するなよとかね
怒るなよとかね 欲張るなよ
それ全部心を清らかにする方法なんですね
怠けるなよと どんなものを見ても
あの 善悪とかね もう神の怒りが降りるんだよと
そんな話じゃなくて もう全部心を強化する方法なんですね
怠けないと思ったら それだけで心は強化します
強くなります 怒らないと思ったら
その心が強くなるんですね
それで全部まとめて使う言葉は
このバハビタという言葉なんですね
仏教では 例えば瞑想というものには
仏教の言葉はバハヴェナなんですね
名詞で で 動詞になるとこのバハヴェティ
それで各文詞になってくるとバハビタという風になってくるんですね
で こちらの訳で この 何でしたっけ
修養という言葉を使ってますからね
それはこの厳密にこの事象から意味をとって修養という意味をとっているんですね
バハビタという言葉に
ですからバハビタというのはその意味なんです
修養という意味 それで
この まあ我々簡単に 例えばすぐ何か見たら欲しがるという場合は心弱いでしょ
簡単に誘惑される 何か見ただけで欲しがっちゃう
あるいは瞬時に怒ってしまうということは弱いということなんですよ
[背景音楽]すぐ諦める
努力しない あるいは最初からチャレンジしないで
まあそんなのはできっこはないと思うでしょ
それも弱いっていうことですね
心が 根性がないと 根性がなければもうチャレンジはしない
それだったら幸福になるはずもない
そこでお釈迦様は無数に方法を教えているんですよ
だから何にしても心育てるということはもう避けられない
必ずも必要な条件なんですよ
そこで我々の目的に応じて語ることもできます
子供がいて勉強しなくちゃいけないということ
学術上達したいんだと
でお釈迦様のお札を首にかけてくださいではないんです
それでその子はそれその目的に必要な心を強化すればいいんです
それで子供は学術のために
それでお父さんがやっぱり収入が足らないんだと
自分の商売を 収入を広げたいんだと
だったら その目的に応じて自分の心を育てることなんです
そうすると 子供の方法とお父さんの方法は少々違ってるかもしれません
少々方法違ってもポイントは同じ
心は強化する それでお父さんは商売繁盛したくて
子供は学問を完成したくてというと
お母さんがもうヒステリーで
もうろくに家のことはできなくなっていると
心が弱いんですね それでお母さんにもあんたは心を強くしなさいと
お母さんの狙いは子供のことでヒステリーを起こさないこと
旦那のことでヒステリーを起こさないこと
家のお仕事はきちんと全部整理整頓して
きちんと家のことをやる
それぐらいの目的だからね
それに合わせて自分の方法を作ればいいんです
だから そのその目的に応じて心を育てる
それと 例えば音楽家になりたいという人がいる
その人は長い間修行するでしょうに
音楽やりたい人 欲を抑えないと
怒りを抑えないと 無知を抑えないとできるわけないんですよ
しかし それで悟るわけじゃないんですよ
音楽家になりたくて修行しているんだと
おまけに悟ったということはないんです
なぜかというと 目的がはっきりしているんだからね
立派な音楽家になりたい人はね
好きな時 好きな食べ物はむちゃくちゃ食べたり
寝たい時は寝たり 遊びたい時は遊んだりしたら音楽家になりますかね
そう なれません ちょっと失敗しただけで
ものすごくカンカン怒ったりとかね
すると音楽家になりません
いろんな この 何て言いますか
もう 何て言いますか 音楽
いろいろね 大会というんですかね
いろんなあるでしょうに
そういうものに出たりする
それで自分が負けたりする
やっぱり負けたんだからって悔しがっちゃうと音楽はなれません
だからそこら辺で一回参加したっても
負けたと またチャレンジ
また負けたと そういう負けても負けても
またまた訓練して 訓練して
自分を自己制御管理して
それでやがて望んだ結果に至るんですよ
例えば大金持ちになりたいという金の欲が出ても
その金持ちになるための道が欲を抑えることにあるんですよ
欲だけだったら体は動かないんです
例えばもう怒りでもう人々をもう殺して殲滅戦にするぞと
イラクをもう塵にするぞと
それぐらい怒りで出ても
戦争に出る若者たちが夜も寝ないで厳しい訓練して
贅沢もなくて 食べるものもろくになくて
砂漠の中で放射能にモロに体を
だからとにかくアメリカはね
放射性物質しか使えないんだからね
鉄砲やら何でもね 劣化ウランで弾頭を作ってますからね
ですから もうこれはイラク人だけじゃないんですよ
放射能被曝するのは とにかくそういう人々は自分の贅沢を抑えて
寝たいという欲も抑えて
しっかりと努力しないと
あの怒りの目的達成することもできないんですよ
例えば アメリカ兵隊がただ怒りだけに狂っちゃうと
それだけで負けちゃうんです
怒りだけに狂っちゃうと
もうどこでもいいんだから
無差別に殺ししまえばいいんだからね
そんなことやっちゃうと
もう戦争に負けるんですよ
だからもう面白いことというのは
世の中でそういう汚い
醜い 恐ろしい目的に達するためにも
道は心を育てることにあるんですよ
当然そういうことは仏教は完全に否定する
例えば銀行強盗をするために 3ヶ月間飲まず食わず計画を立てたと
3ヶ月間飲まず食わず計画を立てる
その計画が立派な計画できたということは
よく頑張ったということになるんですよ
だから 計画ぐらいでも貪瞋痴を抑えないと
バカにはできませんだからね
計画を立てることは 客観的な判断ないと精密に時間計算したりしないとできないんだからね
だからこのブッダははっきり言ってどんなものでも成功したいと思うならばね
道が心を育てることであると
それで心を育てるということは
心の汚れを落とすことであって汚れをなくすことだから
この心の汚れを完全になくすことを教えているんですよ
心の汚れを完全になくすということだったら
人間にあるすべての問題は解決するはずなんです
銀行強盗も消えるはずなんです
貧しい人々はいなくなるはずなんです
他人の国を侵略することはなくなるはずない
夫婦喧嘩も家庭の内紛のない暴力も全部なくなるはずなんです
そういうことで この心を育てるということは
まあいろんな方法で教えていて
今日の偈でも まあこの屋根に例えてわかりやすく
そこは誘惑ということなんだから
この外の情報に心が もろに影響を受けると心が
あまりにも弱すぎ 強くない
だから弱い木が柔らかい土地で伸びているならば
もう風が吹くと簡単に倒れちゃいますね
あまりにも脆い そこら辺で巨大な石とか山があったらね
そんな風が吹いてもびくともしない
その他も別なところで
同じ法経でね セーローヤターエーカガノーワーテンナサミーレティ エーワンニンダーパサンサス ナサニンジャンディパンディタという偈がありますけど
そうやって世の中にある我々の日常茶飯事で見えるたとえから
強い心と弱い心ということは教えてくれているんですね
この場合はものすごくもう弱い屋根のことで
だから家を作るということは
家の中で安全で楽に住むために家を作る
それだったらしっかりして屋根を葺きなさいと
それだったら雨漏れはしないと
そのように心を守っておきなさいと
外の情報 外の誘惑が心を貫いて心を汚さないようにということになるんですね
だから このたとえを使うと
我々は心にガードをつける
外からの攻撃は入らないように
ガードを作るという概念で言っているんですね
では 心に我々はどんな守りをつければよろしいかと
どんな攻撃にも耐えられる
壊れない 潰れない 強力なガードをつけておけば
心はそれで成長して育てていきます
例えば 心は完全にプロテクターをかけておくと
外からは全く汚れが入らないんだったら
その人の課題は心に残っているところ綺麗にするだけ
心にプロテクターかけてないと
いくら心を浄化しようとしても
外から次から次へとゴミが入りますからね
もうやりきれなくなっちゃうんです
そういうわけで 心にとにかく一番早い方法っていうのは
まず完全なガードをつけておく
そのガード論で で 結構その方が仏教経典の中で数が多いんですね
ガードする場合 お釈迦様はこれつのつのところで守れと
眼耳鼻舌身意という 攻撃来るの
来るところはね つだけですよと
敵はこのつの隙間から攻撃かける
つのところはきちんとガードしておけ
眼耳鼻舌身意という まあ敵というのは当然貪瞋痴ですね
欲と怒りと無知なんですね
それで眼から貪瞋痴が入る
で その場合もお釈迦様のすごい実践的なところっていうのは
その時は痴を 無知を使わないんです
眼からはもう貪瞋痴が入るはずなんですけど
お釈迦様が説法するときは怒りと欲だけ言うんです
その方がわかりやすいんですよ
我々は眼で物を見ると欲が出てくる
あるいは怒りが出てくる
その方がわかりやすい
そこで眼を使いますが
ガードかける あるいはプロテクターかけておく
それかフィルターかけておく
このフィルターかけておくと
眼から入る情報は 怒りと欲は入らない
情報は入るんだけど 怒りと欲はこのフィルターでもうそこら辺でもう入らなくなっちゃいます
だから情報はある程度で
そのまま入るというかね
とにかくこのフィルターかけておくんですね
で 我々の耳から怒りと欲が生まれてくる
耳にもガードつけておくと
ガードは簡単です 何を見ても怒ったりしないぞと
何を見ても欲を出したりしないぞと決めるだけなんです
何を聞いても怒ったりはしないぞと
欲張ったりはしないぞ
舞い上がったりしませんと
耳にガードかけておく
何を嗅いでも欲と怒り作りませんと
何を味わっても欲と怒りは作りませんと
体でどんな感想を受けても欲と怒りは作りませんと
頭で何を考えても欲と怒りは作りませんと
無知は置いておく なぜならば
もう弱い我々には無知なんかそう簡単に発見できない
だからその場合は見事に実践的に実行しやすく語られています
それで欠けてますかと無知が
無知が欠けているんだから
これ良くないんではないか
そうじゃない ブッダが教えたものだから
方法は完全なんです 心配する必要はない
なぜならば 目から怒りと欲が入らないようにするぞということをすると
もう智慧が生まれてくるんですよ
それに気づいていないとできないんですよ
それに気づいているということは
無知ではないということなんです
だから智慧が現れると
オートモードで無知が消えていくんですよ
だからわざと無知に戦わなくても
この六根を守りますよということをしたら
そこで無知はもうカットしているんです
だからすごい完璧に語られているものなんですね
要らんものは言わない
実行不可能なものは言わない
個人個人の人間には怒りと欲ぐらいは発見できるはず
発見するということは智慧の働きであって
私たちはもう何か見たら何のことなく欲が出てくるということは無知ということなんですね
観察能力ないということでね
そういうふうに心にガードかける
それ一つの六根を守るとかね
もうかなり難しいんですから
それはもうはっきりとこの出家に行ってるんですよ
出家の戒律は4つありますから 4
つの1つはこれなんです
眼耳鼻舌身を守ってやる
怒りと欲が生まれないように
これかなりきついんですよ
生半可ではできるものじゃないんです
ですから この４種類の戒律の中で一つ
それからまた心にガードをかける方法っていうのは
この思考から汚れが生まれるんだから
私は偉いぞと 我々の民族が一番偉いぞとかね
あの民族は卑しい民族やとかね
そういうふうな思考から
もうものすごく心が汚れて
人間が不幸になって問題を起こしたりして
自分も他人も不幸にするんですから
ですから このどうせ汚物のような汚い思考流れているんだから
その代わりに綺麗なものを流してもらう
最近テレビでニュースでやったなんか何とか魚が大量にこの東京の川にボラですね
入ってるんだと それはやっぱり川が綺麗になったっていう証拠だと
ものすごいたくさん もう魚たくさん上に見たことないんだから
みんなもうそんなたくさん見ると気持ち悪いと言っている人もいましたけどね
ものすごい可愛いんですよ
口を開けてみんな一斉に
もう水が見えないほど大量に来るんだからね
私はそれ見てものすごく可愛くて可愛くてたまらなかったんですね
なんて可愛いんですかと
そこで前はその川で何が流れたというと
この汚物ばっかり流れていたんですね
そのまま それで東京都とJRがなんとか契約を交わして
東京駅の地下水を全部ポンプでくみ上げて
その川に送るんですね
それで１年 ２年経ったらもう川が綺麗になってるんです
ただそれだけのことで
だから同じ法則 仏教でも使ってます
くだらない妄想 汚物みたいな思考を回転しないで
頭の中でひたすら 例えば生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにと
それを回しておく 頭の中で
回して 見てみなさいよと
結果はと お釈迦様 その生きとし生けるものが何の差別も区別もしないで
一切の生命に対して 一切の生命って何ぞや？とか
そんなくだらない妄想はどうでもいいんです
無意味な哲学思考 そんなのはもう面倒くさくてうるさくてね
そんなのは置いておいて
何のことなく ひたすらすごい軽い気持ちで
穏やかな気持ちで その１行だけ回転してみる
サッビーサッターボーンツクタッターという
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
それは川が綺麗になったような感じで
みんなびっくりするほどボラが大群が入ってくるということになるんです
入りすぎと言えるぐらい
それも一つの心をプロテクトする方法なんですね
汚物を回せるんじゃなくて
綺麗な思考を回しておく
そういうふうに瞑想っていうのはたくさん出て出来上がっちゃいますよ
一つっていうことではなくて
もう一つは死随観というね
死を観察する 生命は誰でも死ぬものだと
私ももう短い時代 いつ死ぬかわからないんだと
何やっても死で終わるんだよと
だから死という概念はメインポイントになると
その人の心から欲と怒りが消えちゃうんですよ
イラクを潰してだけ潰してでも我々の収入を確保すると
そんな気持ちにならなくなっちゃうんです
大量破壊兵器作って もうみんな脅かしてやるぞとかね
それはあまりにも無知な
あまりにももう残酷な
もう人間する思考じゃないんですよ
だから僕らみたいな人間にどういうふうに人を殺すことを考えるかと
それも想像できないんですよ
我々のは人を殺すどころか動物に怒ることもできないんだから
怒ったっても動物はわかりもしないんだけど
どこかでやっぱりかわいそうやって気持ちになってくるんですよ
だから仏教はそういう思考なのに
これ平気でもう科学的に研究しながら武器開発するあの人々っていうのは何者ですかと
暗闇でも見えるようにとかね
動物に隠れていても人間を発見できるようにとかね
宇宙からでも見て もう人間をもうと動物を区別するように機械開発とかね
何考えてるんですかと
何者かと 生命かと ウジ虫さえもそんなこと考えないでしょうに
みんな殺してやるぞと
私の偏見かもしれませんだけど
ウイルスさえもそんなこと考えてないんです
ただ たまたまウイルスが体に入っちゃうと体が壊れるだけであって
別に人を殺してやるぞと思ったらウイルスでも生存できませんだから
だからウイルスよりも思考がなんか
どうかなとね まだ同じ生命ですよ
殺そうとしているのは
同類なんですよ 人間が蚊を殺すために色々カラクリやってることとは違うんだからね
だからそこは何なのかというと
やっぱりこのそんなことしたってバカじゃないかと
あなたも死ぬでしょうと
たった死ぬまでの間のこの短い命でしょうと
その間でなんであいつ殺してやるぞ
こいつ殺してやるぞとかね
損じゃないかと だから生まれてから死ぬまですごく平和で
みんなと仲良く楽しくお互いに助け合って
助けてもらったら本当にもう楽しくて
もう助けてもらった 見事にうまいうまいことを助けてもらったとかね
そういうことを思うと
出すとどれほど楽しいんですかね
自分も人だ 誰か助けてあげたらね
ものすごく楽しいでしょうに
この間こういうことがあって
もう私はすぐもう助けてあげましたよとかね
だから助けてあげたり助けてもらったり
その両方もすごく幸福でしょうに
生きて生かしてという論理はね
だからそれができるのは我々は必ずしも死ぬものやと
[終始背景音楽]一挙的にこの地球で
もう地球を食って生きるために現れたもんじゃないんだと
誰かのバカがお前らは地球を支配しなさいと言ったわけじゃないんだと
誰かのバカが言ったそうですね
地球人間には地球を支配せなさいと
で それに乗ってみんな地球を支配しようとしてるんですよ
できるわけない みんな死にますからね
ですから そういうおかしい
危険な 恐ろしい思考 汚物を回転させないで
常に私は死ぬものや みんなもう必ず死ぬんだと
世の中で確かなものはたった一つだよと
それは死なんですよ すべて不確かなんです
客観的に見ればそれは事実ですよ
真理ですよ 例えばこの建物は10年持ちますよっていうのは不確かですよ
いろいろ調べて計算して
あ これだったら10年ぐらいは持ちますよと
持ちません わからない
不確かです しかし 誰にでも一つで壊れますよと
この建物は それだけは100%確かなことなんです
滅びますよと だから世の中で
宇宙の中で確かなものといえば
たった一言ば滅びますよと
なんでそれ嫌がるんですか？事実でしょ
それで死随観という 己の死をはっきりとする
思考の 1番目それにする
他の思考はもう余裕があったらする
商売することは私の人生だと全然絶対思わない
それは生きていればということにする
私は死ぬものよ まだ死んでないんだったら
ちょっと商売でもやりますというぐらいの思考で
それでこの まだ死んでないんだから料理作ってますよとかね
まだ死んでないんだから一応もうなんとか商売やって
そういう気持ちはすごい気持ち楽ですよ
一節はかかりません これは仕事を命だと思ってるんだから
宗教よりも大事だと思ってるんだから
自分の命を だから仕事できないんですね
みんな失敗する ですから
この心を清らかにする
心をガードする この 2番目の法っていうのは別な思考
回転してもらう この別な思考でもブッダが妄想は認めません
真理を開展させてもらう
私は死にますという で
私は死にますという言葉を使いませんですけど
すごい普遍的に 死は普遍的なものである
私も死から逃れているものではありません
確かに私にも死が来る
そういう風にすごいかっこよく念じるんですよ
これパーリ語では二言葉にまとめてます
ジーリタンアニヤタンマラナンニヤタン
四つですけどね 表現としては 2つに分けられます
これずっと念じるんです
ジーリタンアニヤタンマラナンニヤタンジーリタンアニヤタンマラナンニヤタンといつでもできるでしょうに
歩きながらも料理しながら
洗濯しながら 散歩をしながら
くだらない思考は入れない
ジーリタンアニヤタンマラナンニヤタンジー
これはパーリ語でやる人々にとっては便利ですけど
なかなか便利な日本語にはならないし
だからその辺で皆様の天才的な能力をお借りして作りたいんですけど
パーリ語はジーリタンアニヤタンマラナンニヤタン
ジーリタンというのはライフ
命 生命 アニヤタンというのは
まあ何でしたっけ もう不確定っていうかな
アニッチャのアニヤタなんですよ
[音楽]無常であるというふうな
無常はあんまり使い切ってるんだからね
あんまりこのもうインパクト良くない
ないんですけどね 定かではないかな
命は定かではないと マラナムニヤタン
マラナ 死は定かであると
だからそれは四つの熟語みたいな感じでも入れたりして
唱えやすい 感じやすい言葉にして
そういう概念を頭の中で回転する
それに対する瞑想なんですよ
だから瞑想になってくると
何でもこの極力単純化するんですよ
なぜかというと お釈迦様はよく知っていた
人間ほど愚か者はいないんだと
だから何か言い訳する
正しいものになってくると
何か言い訳して逃げる
逃げて泣く 私は不幸や不幸やとかね
何とかしてくれないんだかと
それで教えたらそれに言い訳をする
そう言ったってもとかね
だからこの真理を語ることほどもう嫌なことはないんですよ
この聞く人々のこの根性のないかというか
情けない状態だからね
だからものすごくもうイライラするというかね
もう嫌で嫌で で 一生懸命泣きながら来るんですよ
ある男性なんですけど
このもう鬱になっていて
もう仕事もしたくない
出かけたくないし あれやこれやとかね
で  ではあんたにまあもうゆっくり色々方法を教えますけど
一応思考が回転すればよろしいということで
もうたまたまでもいいんだから
こちらに来てくださいと
そしたらまあそう言われたっても
一時間ぐらいかかりますと
だったらあんた家でやりますか？と言っても
それやる気にならないんだったら来るなよと言いたいでしょうね
で しつこく私に反論しながら
一つの言うことをやりたくない
だったら来る必要性はないでしょう
だから無知っていうのはそんなもんなんですね
だからこの そういうわけで
お釈迦様がこの方法論を語る場合は極力単純にする
瞑想する時の言葉さえもそうやって一言葉二言葉にする
これ他の人にできないんですよ
一言葉だったらどんな言葉でいいわけじゃないんですよ
真理でなければいけません
ジーヴィタンガニータンマラナニータンと 4つの言葉にしたっても
絶対的な真理でなければいけません
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
パーリ語でサッベーサッターバーントスキタッタ 4つですよ
数えているんです サンタ
しかし その 4つの言葉
真理そのもの どれほどお釈迦様が苦労したかというと
この言語ももう極めて難いと
人間の言葉も退屈してないとできるものではないのです
そこまでしているのにまた文句を言うんだからね
だから簡単に文句言っても地獄に落ちるんだと
だからブッダに逆らうことは母を逆らうことよりものすごい罪だと
自分を産んだ母も父もそれほどあなたのことを心配していないんだよと
だからそれは地獄に落ちるということは
別に脅しでも何でもなくて事実なんですよ
真理に逆らったら不幸になるのは決まってるんだから
お互いに憎しみ合って
苦しみ合って 喧嘩して
もう不幸から不幸行くのはもう決まってることだから
あの私にああいう風に反応したか言った人がそれ一回きりだから
それで病気治ったと思いますかね
治らんでしょうに どんどんどんどん自殺願望が
強くなってきます それだけ
ですからもうブッダの言葉にはまあ逆らわない方がいいということになるんです
ブッダに言われたら無言に守った方がいいと
それ守りやすい 極力方法は単純化しています
それ以上は単純化することはできない
ですから 例えば死の死垂成でも念じる場合は
2言葉で  3つで 4つの言葉で頭の中で回転すればいい
暇がないとは言えないんですよ
玉ねぎの皮をむきながら
なんでそれできないんですかね
日夜の祈りとかで カヨジグッチョサタロドゥガンボガッチャンティサンテマラママラママハって言いますけど
それと大体同じようなものですか
うん  どちらでもいいんですけど
その 4度字の方は  いいえ
まあそれはどちらでもいいっていうことでね
まあこれこそっていうことじゃないんで
全部同じ意味なんですよ
心清らかにする方法だから
心清らかになればいいでしょうに
これのこの石鹸使ったっての
液体石鹸使ったっても
どちらでもいいでしょうに
油の汚れと醤油の汚れじゃ全然違います
白菜使えば だからこの一切の汚れをなくすために
だから不完全な方法だったら
今おっしゃったように油は落ちちゃったんだけど
醤油の墨はそのままっていう
その場合は方法は不完全なんですよ
ブッダが説かれ ブッダに説かれたものだから
方法は完全なんですね
どんな汚れも落ちると
で 次にこのカヨジグッチョ
体が不浄なものであると
ただ生きているんだから
熱があるんだから なんとなく生きているような感じ
本当は痛いですよと 痛いっていうのは痛みではなくて
この痴態ということ ものすごく臭い悪臭を出すんだと
それが事実でしょうし
体から出るものは何か汚くて醜くて悪臭のみ
なのに人間の思考はどうですかね
我こそは美しく清らかで偉そうと思ってるでしょ
そういう根拠のない妄想だから
人間がかなり苦しんでいる
だから自分たち誰であろうとも悪臭出す
ただのもう生きてる遺体だよという感じでいるとね
他人をバカにすることできますかね
特にこの貧しい国々をもうもういじめることなんかはね
自分たちこそ偉いとか立場でね
あんなのはできなくなるんですよ
それいじめられる側の人だって
まあどうせ誰でも同じだからね
今威張ったってもという感じで落ち着いてられる
だから一部だけではなくてね
例えば人をいじめる側にしても
そういう気持ちがあったら
私の体っていうのは何やと
ただの腐りかけてるんではないか
もう瞬間瞬間腐りかけてる遺体でしょうと
一日体洗わなかったらどうなるものかと
だから体は部品 部品 何一つ観察しながら
やっぱり汚い 醜い 悪臭のものだよと
その思考を回転させるとかね
その場合はちょっとなんか熟語みたいなものは出てこないんですよ
体は不浄であるという瞑想はちょっとやりにくいんで
説明だけでは それでお釈迦様はそれやりやすいようにしているんです
体を部品に分けてくれてるんです
三十二に その分け方はものすごい面白いんですよ
全くも医学的じゃないんです
しかし そのままなんです
例えば体を何でできてるかというと
まあ結石 それから唾液
そういう風にね 膿 液体だったらそういうリストがあります
アッスワサケーロシンガーニカラシガムッタンというリストなんですね
アッスは涙 ワサはこの体の油
ケーラは唾液 シンガーニカっていうのは鼻水
ラシカっていうのは滑液
この関節の中に入っているこの透明な液体
滑液 ああいうのはもう汚いんだと
見たら気持ち悪いと そういう風に部品に分けてます
骨 皮膚 肉 医学的じゃないでしょ
では どんな医学者にもその三十二でできてないと言えますかね
一つも抜けてないんです
これがものすごい 私はすごい分析やと思いますよ
体の 中できてる部品は一つも抜けてはない
が 一つは医学的にではないんです
だからその三十二に分けてあって
その中で一つか二つぐらい頭の中で回転する
例えば骨という言葉はね
スケリトンという英語の言葉がありますけど
スケリトンは日本語になるとどうなりますかね
骨 骸骨 みんな骸骨やと
私も骸骨だと だから簡単 전에骸骨
骸骨 骸骨と そういう何か一つだけでも十分ですね
そういう風になるともう結構心が綺麗になります
人を見て あ なんて美しい人と思えなくなっちゃうんですよ
骸骨や なんて汚くて醜くて敵やと思えないんですよ
もう骸骨でしょということになるんですね
骸骨が骸骨に当たったって別にいいんじゃないんですか？だって
例えばすごい悪い人見て
私 私を怒鳴ったりけなしたりするとね
まあ骸骨は骸骨にそんなん言ったって別に気にするもんかと
すごく穏やかでいられます
もう一つは呼吸 生きるっていうことは
ただまあ空気を入れ替えている機械でしょうと
吸ったり吐いたり吸ったり
どんなにただの空気入れ替えている機械ではないかと
命っていうのはもう吸ったり吐いたりすることじゃないか
それでなんだとそれ それだけのことではないかと
生命ってそんなもんでしょ
別に ただもう空気を入れたり出したり入れたり出したり入れたり出したり
それで我こそ偉いとかね
あなた方は何なのかとかね
私はたくさん儲けなくちゃいけないんだと
大量破壊でもしてでも私はもう性罰になる
ありえないで そんな話は
ただの空気入れ替えている機械だけなのに
これが呼吸瞑想なんです
呼吸瞑想は不浄随観に入ってます
不浄随観に入ってる  別
不浄随観は不浄随観 呼吸瞑想は呼吸瞑想
呼吸随観ですよ そういう風に私は説明すると
まあ偉大なる呼吸瞑想をなさっている方々は
なんか私は間違っているのではないかと思うかもしれません
だけどそちらが間違っているんです
随分呼吸に集中して 呼吸こそ命やとかね
まあ頑張ってください
ブッダの呼吸瞑想はそんなもんです
ただの吸ってます 吐いてます
それを続き瞑想しまして
その時にただこれだけだよっていうそういう意味なんですけど
もう一つ 先ほどの三十二部心の最初のから二十までの地の様子でございます
最初のから二十までの地の様子でございます
地水火風 二十から三十二まで水のようで
これは水の様だけ並び替えたのはそれも何か意味がある
それは別な瞑想がありますから
それに連絡するために
そういうリストを 単なるリスト
ただ並んだだけでもないんです
地水火風にする目的もあるんです
地水火風の瞑想もありますから
どんな瞑想でもお互いに連携プレイで悟りに行くため目的だから
ここら辺はちょっとあまりにも専門的でね
で お釈迦様のこの作り方を考えると
もうどうにもならんほどあんまりにも驚くんですよ
だから全部一つ一つ繋げてるんですよ
実践するときは一個取ってやるんですけど
だから私はこれしかやってないんだってことにならないんですよ
一個やったら全部わかって終わっちゃうという
見事にこの連携させてます
説明するとまるっきり別々な瞑想のように見えてしまいますが
道は同じ 結局同じ結果で終わります
自我がなくなって 心が綺麗になって
智慧が開花して 解脱してしまうという
[笑い]だからこの地水火風に
あの完璧にあの三十二は分けられませんだから
このケサーローマーナカーダンタータチョーマンスァンナハルーアッティーアッティミンジャーワッカガで
全部だいたい土にしますね
それからアンカーさんピッターンセンマンプーボーロイタンセードメドワスワサケーロシンガーニカラシカムタンっていうのは水になっちゃうんですね
で 風はもう入ってないんですね
火も入ってないんですね
で そこはもう欠けてると思うんだったら
だったら次第増というんですか
地水火風の瞑想しなさいと
それまた地水火風の説明聞くとものすごく難しいんですよ
しかし 実践する場合は
そんな難しい知識 学問絶対使わない
学問 知識使うと妄想だから瞑想ではないんです
全くもう子供から大人まで誰でもできる方法でやるんです
どういう方法かというと
自分の体でね 硬い 硬いんだったら地
流れるもの それは水 それだけでやるんです
動いているものは それは風
空気とか動いてるんだから
それ風 熱は熱で火 それだけで瞑想に
まあそんな四つでできてるんだから
それ以外何もないと 体には硬いものがあって
流れるものがあって 動くものがあって
熱があると 全部まとめて何も漏らさず
それ四つに入るんです
それで手を上げたりして
これは何か 風ですよ それで学識入っちゃうと
なんで手を上げること風になるんでしょうかと
使わない 動く 動くものは動きは風
熱は熱で火 それは単純で硬いだったら土
それだけ その瞑想の場合
もうちょっとステップ
ステップあります そこでこちらの硬いものは土で
周りの硬いものは全部土で全く同じものやと
こちらに流れるものは水で
外の世界で流れるものは一切は全部水やと
まるっきり同一である
私の体の熱は火で そこら辺で火がそれも同じ火ですよと
火ですよ 熱ですよと 全くも同一やと
その瞑想でいけば もうまたもう他人自分というその気持ち
全部消えてしまっちゃって
怒りも欲ももう何に怒るんですかね
土が土に怒るんですかね
水が水に怒るんですかね
何のこともなくなっちゃいます
ある一滴の水が別な一滴の水に恋をしましたと
成り立たなくなっちゃうんです
それはこの止水海仏という瞑想のやり方で
まだまあそれぐらいで十分でしょう
まだたくさんありますけど
そういうふうな方法で
しかし 瞑想が複雑になるとうまくいかない
瞑想がもうこれ以上はないというところまで単純でなきゃダメなんです
それブッダの方法論なんです
だから瞑想するための前の準備
いろいろ儀礼 儀式 清め
儀式 あれやこれやとかね
服装を決めたり 道具を決めたりすると
もう全部妄想の世界で
真理の世界ではありません
だから余計なことはかすかにでもあると
人間が言い訳したり バカないい加減なことを言って逃げちゃう
例えば毎日瞑想する前におジュースでも首にかけておけと言ったら
これ何か言うんですよ
やっぱりジュースは朝ちょっと寒く感じますよと
首回りが 自分の皮膚には合わないんだよと
なんとかいう 人間の愚かさっていうのはもう呆れちゃうほど愚かなんですよ
だから言ってみなさいよと
できるならという態度でお釈迦様はおっしゃっているんです
こういうわけでできないんだよと
あれば言ってみなさいと
だからもう完全にもうバカだからバカにされているんです
だからもう頑張るしか道がないんです
かすかにでもプライドあるんだったら頑張るしかもう
頑張った人は成功するのもまた確実なんです
そういうことだから もういろんな宗教であらゆる儀式
なんとかありますけど
全く無駄です 私は死に至るものだということを玉ねぎ剥きながらできますからね
お釈迦様教えてる瞑想は全部そういう風にできます
人の時間は取らないんです
それヴィパッサナーだけじゃないんです
だからまあ 厳密にこの科学的にこの心そのものにアタックするして悟らせる方法というのはヴィパッサナーになるんですね
それは何か手術するような感じで
もうガンだったら開けて捨てると
長い間この玄米食べて
有機栽培の野菜を食べて
空気の綺麗なところに住んでガンを治すというと
治る前に人が死ぬ可能性もあるし
治る場合も治らない場合もあるし
もう手っ取り早いのはもう開けて切って捨てると
もうガンはないと だから瞑想の中で一番王様はもう極力瞑想っていうのはヴィパッサナー瞑想
それが智慧そのものを育てる
すべての煩悩が無知が作りますから
怒りも欲もすべての煩悩
嫉妬も憎しみも あらゆる煩悩が無知が作るんだから
智慧の瞑想で無知を破ると
それで全部煩悩が落ちちゃう
わかりやすい例で言えば
ある入れ物があって あらゆるものが入っている
この入れ物を綺麗にしましょうというと
一つ二つ取って取って
またそのゴミをね もう中にあるものはいろいろ整理して
あっちこっち置いたりして時間かかるんですよ
この入れ物欲しいんだったら
もうパーッと全部投げて
はいどうぞと その時にはあるんです
そういうこと それはヴィパッサナーのやり方で
だから最終的な瞑想はヴィパッサナーになるんです
それ失敗すると  してはいけません
それで終わり 不浄の瞑想はうまくいかないんで
まあいいや別に だったら別なことを教え上げますと
ヴィパッサナーだけは失敗できない
それ以上以外はない この十三と十四で言ってるこの屋根をかけるっていうのはヴィパッサナー
だからそのどんな瞑想を含めいいんですよ
眼耳鼻舌身意を守るっていうのは観察がある
それがヴィパッサナー
だから眼耳鼻舌身意観察
それは戒律に入れてますから
あの戒律守ることもヴィパッサナー瞑想になるし
ですから このやっぱりこの全部一つにつなげていますから難しいんですよ
で ヴィパッサナー 例えばサティを実践する人が眼耳鼻舌身意守っている
それで心に汚れが入らないでしょ
実況中継すると だから他の瞑想を別にやらなくてもいいっていうことになってるんです
だからそれで解決しちゃうんです
それで ヴィパッサナーで
だから無数にいる敵を一人一人見つけては殺すか
一発で原子爆弾を落とすかという
だから煩悩という敵は
このまとめて一発でも殲滅する方法っていうのはヴィパッサナーっていう方法
それで心はこの瞬間に気づくことで
心はとっても忙しくさせる
ものすごく忙しくしてよ
それでもあらゆる能力が自動的にもう心が動かしてますからね
能力も現れてくる 全くも汚れない
何も瞑想の中でも最終はもうヴィパッサナーになるんです
で あの注釈書などでは他の瞑想
例えば呼吸瞑想はもうどんどん洗浄作って
第一 二 三 四まで行って
それからその呼吸瞑想もやめて
無色界の洗浄して うーむとか長い分厚いテキストでしょうに
ずーっと説明していますよ
それで能力開発の場合はどういう風に
どういう風にとかね 結局ヴィパッサナーのところになってくると
あれは全部やめてっていうふうに始まるんです
今までの修行はね 何十年もかかったのに
あれは全部やめて すごく普通の知識で体の部品を観察すると
それからこのヴィパッサナーで発見するのは
無常 苦 無我という三つのひとつですけど
それは智慧で自動的に現れるものでと同時に悟りますので
はい だから無常っていうのは
この生半可で中途半端で私たち言ってる気持ちというわけでもないんですけどね
無常を知った時点で悟っているはずなんですね
でも無常っていうのはですから
この不可思議な神秘像じゃないんです
ごく普通のことなんですけど
なのに悟らないのはなんかおかしいんですね
それは頭に妄想概念があるんだからなんです
ありがたいことはいっぱい頭の中に溜まっているんだから
ありがたいとは全てクソなんですよ
だからクソがありがたい宝物と思ってる間は
その人はクソと一緒に生活しなくちゃいけないことになるんですね
だからこの無常っていうのは
分かったらそこでもう悟りなんですよ
無常でも空でも無我でもどちらでも同じなんですけど
そんなに難しいことじゃないんですが
なんか私たちは頭が変でどうも納得いかないんですね
無常には  先生 その段階っていうのはないんですか？ある程度わかるとか
わかったら悟るっていうのは
わかったらわかった  七覚支っていうものですね
あれはヴィパッサナーの修行の段階っていうことではないんですか？ 段階じゃない
ではないんですか？どういうものですか？七覚支とヴィパッサナーとの関係っていうか
一番最初のは念で始まりますから
全くそれだけ見れば同じです
念始めれば他は全部オートモードでついてきますしね
それはね 卵焼き作りたいんだったら
あれなんとかフライパンあるでしょ
こげない 焦げない テフロンの方が便利ですよ
ということは テフロンがなければ卵焼きできないっていうわけじゃないんですけど
やっぱりめちゃくちゃになるんですね
ちょっとよくわかりません
普通の鉄板で卵焼き作っちゃうと綺麗に取れないでしょうに
だから無茶苦茶になったり壊れたりしちゃうと
自分だけ食べるんだったらいいんだけど
でも自分したっても自分がいいわけないでしょうに
それでテフロンのプライパンで作っちゃうと
別に油使わなくたっても
さっともう立派に出来上がっちゃうんですよ
そういうことで この精進なんかあった方が怠けるよりはね
怠けてやったっても立派には役に立ちません
そのサティは そういうことで
七覚支っていうのは まあそういう
七覚支っていうのはどっちかっていうとテフロンのフライパンのことを言ってるんですか
うん  どうもありがとうございます
だから七支ですからね
例えばもうテフロンで焼いても
この箸で取ろうとするとうまくいかないんですね
いかない まあいく人もいるかもしれませんだけど
やっぱり真ん中半熟状態なんかにしちゃうと
もうまた皿に持っていく間で壊れる可能性もありますね
それにはちょっと幅がある
あるでしょ？なんとかな
フライ返しですか  まあなんかありますね
それで取っちゃうと大丈夫ですね
それも付け加えてもらおう
それ精進ですか  まあそういう
まあどっちでもいいんですけど
そういう風にこの仕事は上手に完璧に何にも間違いもないようにするために必要な条件ということなんです
あの なんていうか ヴィパッサナーやってるとですね
自分自身ではなんか変化は感じる時もあるありますけど
不安になるっていうか
これでいいのかなっていう時がやっぱりあるんですけど
そういう時に七覚支みたいのはあるとですね
自分自身はこういうことなのかなという風に思える時もあるんですけども
まあ七覚支は条件ですから
不安になったりするのは妄想したっていうことだからね
それはそれそれでいいことですか
それだけのことですよ
別に妄想しなきゃ不安にならないでしょ
あれへとこれと考えなくちゃ不安にならないでしょ
あれとこれと考えるなかれということだから
不安になるはずがないんですね
何も考えていないならばね
だからそんなにね まあ不安になったら不安になったっていうぐらいで実況すればそれでもう消滅するもんです
それでね 心を守る方法として
この無常の瞑想もあります
頭の中でも何でも無常であると回転させちゃう
あの またちょっと前に戻りましたけど
あのあの 心をプロテクトするために
まあ何 まあそんなまあ無常なものだからね
永遠なものじゃないですよ
壊れるものに無常なものに自分に対しても何に自分の知識
そんなのはもうそのうち消えてしまいますよとかね
まあまあみるみる体が壊れていくもんだよと
だから人が怒って喧嘩したって
まあそんな怒りもね 大したものではない
すぐ消えるもんでしょうと
人があんた あんた素晴らしい人間やと信頼しても
まあそのうちその気持ち変わりますよと
ああやって何も気にしないようにする
それは無常の瞑想なんです
それでこのドゥッカの瞑想もありますし
無我の瞑想もあります
そういうどんな瞑想でても
あの心を守られて悟りには至ります
先生 そのいろいろな瞑想っていうのは
自分でこういうのをやろうかなと思ってやってよろしいですか？あの
静意観とか無常の  まあ向き不向きもありますけどね
格好つけてあれもやりました
これもやりましたっていうことは何の意味もないんですね
大体は一つしかやらない
一つやったらこれで完成です
一つやった人には他の瞑想は何も説明できません
うまくいけばね で ただ
例えば中途半端で一つやってみて
じゃあこの瞑想一年もやったことで
次に次の瞑想に では不浄観で一年やってみると
はい それも一年終わったんだから
次に無常観で一年とかね
それでももう何年やっても
そのいわゆる評価するぐらいの結果は得られないんですが
まあやってるのブッダの瞑想であるならば
まあその分は結果は必ずあります
心は綺麗な状態では続きますけどね
悟りや智慧までは至らない可能性あります
中途半端な場合は 真剣にかかるとどんな瞑想も同格で同じ結果にはなります
あの 心綺麗にするとか
まず美しい心を作るってよく言うんですけど
汚れを落として心が綺麗になると智慧が出てくる
自動的に出てくると思いますね
で 美しい心っていうのは智慧なんですか？作るものなのか
それとも心を綺麗にすると自動的にそういうことができてくるものなのかっていうのはちょっと
うん で こういう風に考えれば
心の汚れを落とすことが智慧なんです
そうすると同時でしょ
うん 智慧っていうのは別なものだと取っちゃうと仏教的でなくなっちゃう
別な何か導入しちゃうと
それも何か現象が導入したことだから
もうそんな大したことじゃないんですよ
何でも無常で見る場合はね
そのうちなくなりますよってことになりますね
だから何か別なものを導入するんじゃないんですね
汚れを落とす それに智慧という
だから智慧の場合に悟りの場合はなくなりましたっていうことはありえないんですね
そういうことで この何でしたっけ
あの質問があの 育てた心っていうのはどういうことかと
わからないっていうことで
それ答え出したんです
で この芸のね 中心ポイントはね
そこら辺だからね 心を守るという
汚れが入らないように守る
どのように守るかというと
もう全て仏教はそれを語ってますので
あらゆる方法がありますし
どちらでもより取り見取りで方法はあるので
あの１つ取って真剣に実況すると
性格的には向き不向きもあるし
例えばパーリ語でうまくいくんだけど
日本語でうまくいかないっていうこともあるし
それはまあその々の文化の差で
お釈迦様はそれぞれの国民に自分にぴったしはめる方法でやってくださいと言われているしね
例えば妄想と実況中継という二言を私はずっと使ってるでしょ
で それで日本ではうまくいってますけど
理解と思ってるだけですけど
私はね で これは外国語ではうまくいかないんですよ
この二言葉も しかし 私たちから考えれば妄想
それが問題でしょうし
妄想しなきゃいいのに
妄想さえなくなっちゃったら智慧がないんだから
妄想する妄想がなくなったっていうことは智慧があるっていうことで
だから妄想を落とすことが智慧が現れることで
で それで悟りであるし
ですから妄想っていうのはもうすごい説明するときはもう絶対必要な条件なんですよ
絶対必要になるんですね
この絶対必要な言葉が英語で説明すると使えないんですよ
単語がないんです で だからね
もし私は英語での指導することになっちゃうと
まるっきり新しい方法と新しい概念で組み立てないと
実況中継っていう言葉はなかなか使えないんですよ
そういうことだから この
そういうふうな言語的な問題やらね
例えば頭の中で回転する言葉だったら
いつも同じに回転できないと
なんかやりにくいんですよ
だから頭の中でも発想するんだから
で よりそういうふうなところは
まあその々の人々は自分で考えなくちゃいけないんですね
パーリ語でやる人にとっては
例えば四念処の場合は
ジータンガ ニータン マラナン
ニータンのですけど それも取ってマラナン
ニータン マラナン ニータンだけでも十分ですよ
でもそんな簡単に簡単な日本訳できるかというと
なかなか簡単な日本訳は成り立たなくなっちゃうし
それから我々の言葉だったら
この不浄という言葉がすごい強烈なんですよ
うん ものすごい強烈な言葉なんです
だから不浄観の瞑想はすごいしやすい
でも日本語で不浄と言ったっても
なんかそんなにニュアンスは感じないんですね
不潔とかはもっといいかもしれません
日本人が不潔って言っちゃうと
ちょっと嫌な感じになるんでしょうね
やっぱり不浄じゃない
不潔ですよ 正しい言葉は
汚れてるっていうのとは違う
それまで違うんですね
だから体は不潔であると
そういう実際はそういう単語選びとかね
結構難しいし だから瞑想たくさんあるんですけど
向き不向きありますし
性格的にもぴったしはめるはめないということもあるしね
でも最澄瞑想は全ての人類に合います
ヴィパッサナー 説明する説明の仕方がね
変わりますけどね 英語だったら我々よく使うのはマインドフルネスというね
言葉なんですけどね 妄想には英語の単語ありますけど
私は日本語で使う妄想という意味にはならないんですね
いわゆる 難しい とにかく心がガードしていないとどんどん汚れていくということで
ガードには 4つあると最初におっしゃったと思うんですけども
ガードには 4つあってですね
いえ ないない それはそれは戒律は 4つあると
この戒律の 4つで 一つはこの 6つの基本をガードすること
その戒律 4つもやっぱり出家戒律ですよ
このエピソードはね お釈迦様の義理の弟ではないんですけどね
腹違い弟でしたからね
まあ弟でしたけどね そういうエピソードはあまり合わないね
律令にはね お釈迦様は強引に出家させたんですよ
結婚しようとしていたのに
お釈迦様はかなり大胆ですよ
ものすごい大胆 もうやることっていうのはもう全く人間はやらないということばっかしだからね
だからこの自分の弟がね
自分が家を出たんだから
もう国を守らなくちゃいけないというすごい責任があって
で 父親が年で で この人は宮殿作ってすごい美人美女のね
女の人がいて その人結婚することになって
だからまあ宮殿の開会と結婚式で同時に国王がお釈迦様のお父様なんですけど
まあこれから君に任せるというね
お父さんもいくらが引退したいんですよ
だから家のこと考えるんだったらすごく大変
お釈迦様助かる お釈迦様の責任でもあるんだからね
自分が逃げちゃって で
それでいくらなんでも釈迦族のものすごい偉大なる人物は釈尊で釈迦族だけではなくて
インド中どこでも尊敬されているんだから
釈迦族の人々はもうお釈迦様のことはもう仏教は信じなくても
お釈迦様のことはものすごい大事にするという
釈迦族みんな仏教ってわけじゃないんですよ
しかし 釈尊は自分たちの民族から出てきた
もう人類のリーダーであるということはもうよく分かっている
それだけは自慢する ですから
この弟はもう言うこともなく
やっぱりお釈迦様を呼びますということで呼ぶんですね
お布施しますと で 彼が考えたのは
まあ自分がまあお釈迦様がやらなくちゃいけない仕事はね
用なしにやらなくちゃいけないし
父親を楽にしてあげなくちゃいけないしね
でお釈迦様もそれなりに応援してくれるだろうと思ったでしょう
で 何のことなくその もう行ったんですよ
行ってお布施をいただいて
で 衣を着替える時はもう自分の鉢を弟にそうやって伸ばしちゃったんですね
そしたらもう上下関係すごい世界だからね
サッと手を出してそれをいただいて
で 持っているんですね
お釈迦様が衣を着るまでは
持ってて何のことなくお釈迦様出かけていくんですよ
出かけたらもう自動的にこの鉢を持って後ろから行かなくちゃいけないんですよ
もう で 恐れ多くてお釈迦様お鉢はという一言は言えないんですよ
これそれが計算するんですね
お互い一緒に大きくなったんだから
もうこの弟はもう自分に対してはもう言うことは何でもすると
自分に対しては口は絶対言わないと
これ知ってます 性格は
兄貴はもう絶対的な上で
で 能力から何から見てももうもうものすごい上でしたからね
だから口は利かない 知ってます
だからお釈迦様お鉢はと言えないんですね
それでそのままお釈迦様はもう寺に戻った
戻って何のことなく部屋に行ったら
あ もう自分の弟がいるんじゃないんだけど
あ なんだ じゃあ君も出家したら
そんなもんで出家されちゃったんですよ
もう大胆というと もうそこで大祭待ってます
その人のこの応答して
この即位儀式も待ってるんですよ
みんな準備して 結婚式と
結婚式終わったら正式的なこの即位儀礼という儀式ですね
これで親戚が集めても国の大事件でしょうね
何のことない これはもう
で ただこの人には嫌と言えないんだからね
性格知ってるんだから
だからまたお釈迦様のこの言葉の使い方もすごい断れないんだそうですよ
この単語はまあお釈迦様ほど使える人はいませんだからね
だからあんたも出家したらって言ったところで
はいはい わかりましたと一言
それっきりその人喋りません
お釈迦様は 言ってサーリプッタサンジャイサーリプッタ
この人は出家したと言ってるんだよと言ってお釈迦様は自分の仕事
もうどうにもならない
サーリプッタ尊者がもう出家させたんですよ
逃げることもできないし
もう突然なことで もう準備もなかったし
そこでものすごいインドで美人として選ばれた人なんですよ
もう結婚したがっていた相手は
インドでは昔から美人コンテストありましたからね
だからもう頭がパニック状態でね
でも一旦王家の育ちだから
やることはもうしっかりやらないとね
負けるということは絶対ない世界でしょう
政治家って王家っていうのは大変ですよ
臆病は負けること 怖くなることは
これはもう頭に叩かないんですね
だから決めた仕事は命令はやるということで
真剣に修行はもう一応やるんですけど
やっぱり心のガードも何もないんですね
それでまあお釈迦さんは別にどうですか
元気ですかと見ないし
あの一言葉でもうそれでハイハイって言っただけで
うまいことサーリプッタ尊者にもう任す
だから正式的っていうのはひとかけらもなし
その場合も それはおかしいんではないかと言ったっても
お釈迦様はまた自分の都合により戒律を変えているんだから
権利あるんだと 自分が兄貴だから
弟に出家認めるという
だからそういうことで
だから彼がやっぱり嫌になっちゃってね
ずっとあの女の人のことばっかし考えてね
もうもう無茶苦茶でしょうしね
家の状態も 父親はどれほどショック受けたでしょうしね
お釈迦様全然気にしない
そんなの で なぜか父親にしたっても
自分の息子に対して文句言えないし
ソッドーダナ王子に対してはものすごい自慢の息子でしたからね
ものすごい親バカで親バカで
息子がやることは何でも正しいと
そんなのは逆らう必要ないんだと
でもお釈迦様の子供出家したとこはやっぱり文句言ったんですよ
あんた 私の 2番目のね
もう子も連れて行ったし
でも子供まで孫までっていうのはちょっと悲しかったと
だからまあ親の悲しみもちょっと理解したらいかがでしょうかと
まあそれで それからは子供の場合は
まあ親の許可が必要やっていうことは
そこで条件つけてあげたんですけどね
だからそういう父親だからね
お釈迦様はそこら辺便利に使って
でもこの人はやっぱり厳粛したかったんですね
何では  [背景音楽]減速したかったんですけど
まあお釈迦様には言えない
ほとんど会ってないと思いますね
出家したからはほとんど会ってないと思います
そこで他のお坊さんたちに会ったりすると
やっぱり私はこうやって突然もう強引にもうやられたらしいですよと
私はもうこんな修行生活はできないんだと
だから戒律ろくに守らない
戒律は守ってたんですけどね
真面目に修行できないんだから
これはもう自分の態度も失速しね
だから帰りたいと そこはお釈迦様の耳に入ったところでお釈迦様はさっさと行って
あの話は申し訳ないとか
何のこともない ナンダは元気？って感じで
まあなんとかと じゃあ一緒に行きましょうと言って
それちょっといると一緒にいく場所があるんだよと言って
そこから注釈書の話ですけど
お釈迦様の神通で天国に連れて行ったと
トソソセンターバジンさんに
そしたらあっちこっちものすごいいっぱい天女たちがいて
この人また頭パニック状態になる
で パニックになったらもうお釈迦様「ナンダ
この蓮華綺麗？」と 綺麗とも何とも
こんなには美しいって
君結婚したかった相手は？あんなメス猿ですよ
比べると それでもうもう僕頭がもうパニック状態で
あまりにも美しい 想像できないほどの天女たちを見て
だったら君ね 私は約束しますからね
こういうもう何人もあなたのものになりますから
ちゃんと修行しなさいと
で 信じられない 本当のお釈迦様が約束します
私約束しますよと ったら
ブッダの約束でしょうし
まあわかりましたと それでしつこくもう修行に頑張ったんです
あの女の人のことはもう綺麗さっぱり消えちゃった
頭の中からひとかけらもなく
だから本人がメス猿に感じちゃ見えてしまった
感じたんだから これ まあ欲っていうのはそんなもんだからね
そんな信頼できませんよ
あなたのことは一生忘れません
別な綺麗な人見たらすぐ綺麗さっぱり消えちゃいます
だから無常っていうのはそんなもんだから
それを知っておけば楽ですよ
人生は だから今になってね
自分の母親が言ったいろんな言葉を思い出しますからね
母の機嫌取りとか お母さんのこと大好きですよとかね
ものすごく馬鹿にされるんですよ
お前らね 今うちだけ今のうちだけですよ
今何もできんだからね
全然ありがたいとか全然ないんですね
なんてなんて可愛いこと言ってくれるんですかとか
この子はとか まるっきりない
それはやっぱり無常で生きてるんだ
生きていたからだと思いますね
もうそんなの今のうちだけですよと
何かあんた必要とかね
その時言う だから日本の感覚とは随分違う
お母さん嬉しいわ そんなこと言ってくれるとかね
まるっきりない ちょっとバカじゃないかというぐらいで終わっちゃう
やっぱり気持ちっていうのはそのうちそのうち変わるんだよということは
その瞬間で教えてあげようとしたんですよ
まあだからナンダさんの感気持ちもまるっきりもう潰れちゃって
それで修行して悟り開けるし
修行する間でもさらにからかわれたんですよ
で もうお釈迦様 なぜならば天女たちに欲があると
また修行はうまくいかないんだから
完成はしませんだからね
で やっぱり他の人にバラしちゃってね
お坊さんたちにね で 知ってます？ナンダ減速したかっている
ナンダはなんで頑張っている知ってますか？というのは
私に約束させるんだよと
この天国の天女たちと一緒になるということ
それで本当ですかと聞くと
これは恥ずかしくて恥ずかしくて
兄貴と自分だけの 話なのに
そこですっごいもう信じられないほど恥かかけられちゃったんですね
偉大なるお釈迦様に約束されるってこと？どういうことかと
こんなの出家にふさわしい方ないろいろ言われちゃってね
さらにもう腹が立つ その時は本当にもう腹が立って
もうそんなという感じで
この勇気が出しちゃったんですね
出してしっかり頑張ったら悟り開いてしまっちゃったんですね
ですから それについてこの偈を語ったんだというんですけど
違うと思いますけどね
だから心はガードしてなかった
なんかちょっと合わないんですね
一応心のどこかでそうやって弱いところがあると
そこからは攻撃は入ります
その点ではなんとか強引に解釈できますけどね
まずこの結婚相手に対しては心がもろい
だからそこからどんどんどんどん煩悩が入り込んで入り込んで入り込んで修行できなくなったりして
それでそれはお釈迦様は消してくれた
別な欲で 天女たちを見せて
しかし天女たちが欲しいやって
そこら辺でまたもろいんですよ
そこでとことんプライド壊しちゃって
もうあまりにもプライド壊しちゃって
孤独したされた状態にしてしまって
そこをもうストップかけちゃったんですね
もう嫌やと だからその人には
たとえいくらか修行して
それから後で天女たちと一緒になることもできたって言っても
断るしか方法なくなっちゃうんだ
もうもし天女と一緒になっちゃって
やっぱりってことになるでしょ
そこまでもなくなるようにしたんですね
だからやっぱり仏教はもうやるんだったらもうプライド持ってしっかりやると
中途半端は絶対もう嫌で
生半可っていうのは全くダメで
はっきりとYes No しておかないと
やるかやらないかと というところはもうしっかりして
だからすごい人格者の世界ですよ
仏教の世界っていうのは
ものすごい人格者たちの
ヴィパッサナーにしても
私はただ怒ってガチャガチャ言ってるわけじゃなくて
この人格の問題で もうあまりにも根性がなさすぎというかね
もう妄想もあまりにももう自分の好き嫌いで物事を嫌
やめなさいと言ってるんだから
もう試しにでもやってみろという
だからこの やればものすごい立派な人間になりますよ
他の根性のない弱々しい人間の間で素晴らしい人間になります
そういうことで頑張ってください
話は終了いたします どうもありがとうございます